[Musik]
herr reiter weg herr reiter werk hier
sind sie reingekommen
ich bin offensichtlich hier eingebrochen
aber
ich mache so etwas normalerweise nicht
ich bin doch eigentlich ein gutmensch
von den grünen
frau doktor doktor bitte helfen sie mir
ich fühle und spüre etwas zutiefst und
grünes in mir
ein braunkohlekraftwerk
um sie zu knechten
nein nein kohle macht unser klima kaputt
das fracking
nein nein fracking ist auch ganz ganz
schlecht für die bürger jetzt also wer
von euch beiden ist jetzt von den grünen
was richtig denn da bitte helfen sie mir
sie leiden ganz klar an einer
persönlichkeitsspaltung lass uns gehen
wir kommen auch ohne diese aufgeblasen
[Gelächter]
guck mal ein nagelneuer atom brennstab
drum brennstab
entschuldigen sie aber ich muss dir und
grün ist echt mal kurz einsperren also
das ist ja auch keine gruppensitzung
hier
braucht man gut danke
endlich ruhe das fühlt sich so ein
bisschen an wie früher als sie noch
grüne politik machen konnten ja aber sie
haben noch einen freien willen was
hindert sie denn jetzt daran gucken sie
mal nachrichten ab und zu kleine pro
team wir wurden damals wegen der
klimapolitik gewählt und jetzt sind wir
für tracking für kohle und für
atomkraftwerke ich kann ihnen helfen
wenn wir uns regelmäßig treffen zwei
drei jahre und ihre
persönlichkeitsspaltung ist gehalt
gehalt was sie
ohne diese spaltung da der
persönlichkeit sind wir grüne doch
wir brauchen sie zum überleben bitte
bitte bitte darf ich mal ganz kurz
rausholen er fürchtet sich im dunklen
wir beide sind noch nicht sich
miteinander überlegen sie doch mal sie
sind doch gerade suppen gibt fühlt sich
das denn nicht toll für sie an wenn ich
ganz ehrlich bin schon aber nein nein
wir grünen wir verkaufen doch gerade
unsere seele
robert habeck versucht ich zitiere sich
vom parteiprogramm fernzuhalten nur
damit die deutschen im winter nicht
frieren müssen
aber keiner friert doch gerne im winter
aber dann können wir unser
parteiprogramm doch gleich
hunderttausendfach auch nicht recycelten
tropenholz papier ausdrucken und durch
den industrie schornstein jagen sehen
sie es mal so ja sie tun gerade das was
getan werden muss dafür hat doch jeder
verständnis was steckt das
verbindet uns denn gerade gut wenn die
industrie das waren früher unsere feinde
und jetzt jetzt müssen wir plötzlich
angst haben vor drei disco future
interessant spaltung mit dem inneren
kind
wir machen jetzt eine kleine
assoziations üben ok bereit so
woran denken sie das erinnert mich an
meine zeit beim nabu
hat das ist der hammer was weg begann
die scheiße was seht ihr hier also was
sehen sie hier weiter weg kaminfeuer das
ist absolut und wörtlich ich meine was
da am co2 haus geblasen wird
endlich das klima interessieren
was ich hier habe
ein mitgliedsantrag der cdu ja auf alle
kinder maßen haben scheißen auch wenn
kein krieg ist sich einmal so gut fühlen
wie friedrich merz
da bin ich dabei
[Gelächter]
wie sollte mich auf exotismus
konzentrieren so ok
sie müssen sich als grüner mal wieder
selbst spüren entspannen sie sich es ist
eine kleine kreuzer hd kostet
kostet
98 euro aber das suchen von ihrem konto
aus gar kein problem ja und diese kröte
nehmen sie und begleiten sie über die
straße drei mal am tag okay
unsere zeit ist schon vorbei ja das tut
mir wirklich wahnsinnig leid immer
schwerer machen ja gar kein problem was
machen wir als nächstes
stehe absolut
klar frauen haben recht ich verstehe
dass das verteidigungsministerium eine
echte belastung ist
liebe mitbürgerinnen und mitbürger
wenn sie alle diesen kanal abonnieren
werde ich vielleicht zurücktreten
vielleicht eher schadet also nicht wenn
sie alle videos leiten ihre christine
lambrecht
deutschland zählt auf sie
[Musik]